live hey everybody welcome to stream
coco
yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah today we're coming
at you on tuesday tuesday crazy day
different day yesterday we were shooting
stuff we couldn't do monday melee but
we're doing stream coco today on tuesday
and we're playing a game you might have
heard of it's called dark souls 3.
[Music]
triple the souls triple the darkness
same amount of threes
yeah yeah sure i don't know what that
means uh welcome everyone intoxicated
penguin janet castle good to see you
fleurley hello hi
buttlicker14
so glad you could make it in the chat
today
now here's the thing guys uh i
suck at dark souls i played it once in
my life i'm terrible at it um
and the game agrees with me
so let's watch a little uh start here
is this like a lord of the rings this is
this kingdom's kind of a fix me up
you know
oh i like i like
it's a turtle person
ooh what are the truth of the old words
that everyone's terrible at dark souls
that's how it works
oh
this oh
so
this game starts off with someone
collapsing
and dying from exhaustion
with the turtle shell on their back
i'm guessing it's a comedy
[Music]
oh no the lords of cinder
like cinderella is that one of the lords
of cinder
saint of the deep oh
oh is that like a
it's like a mud
like a sentient mud
[Music]
people who watch the abyss i guess
doesn't doesn't sound as cool you know
those by the way are just the abyss
watchers are also just couch potatoes
imagine his calories how he has how much
he has to eat to be able to just
maintain that
huge body
also if you're that big do you really
need like a giant sword just squash
people you know what i'm saying oh this
seems very unnecessary yeah he's got a
shady says he's got a hole for a face
the lords will abandon their thrones
oh i wouldn't put that on it's moving
put it on put it on don't put it on
sauron's back said mr scent the
unkindled
there's like so much like unkindled lord
of cinder there's a lot of dramatic
stuff going on in this game and then in
the end like you're just gonna go around
and like shoot yeah in the end i bet
it's just some guy doing this with a
sword no offense
unfit
this guy isn't fit to even be cinder
oh he eats souls
that's why it's called dark souls
oh i see that guy's dead so he doesn't
need any food since the dyslexic gamer
well fair enough
i guess he just needs soul souls are
probably
high in calories yeah that's true all
right let's name ourselves something
what should we name ourselves guys you
guys decide uh what we should name
ourselves everyone ready everyone in the
chat say a name
the lords of the fallen is better how
fast you're gonna die the jed i'm gonna
die so fast
uh we're playing this on xbox one y'all
and so far graphics look amazing um
jordan hank dark cookie oh we gotta name
this guy jordan schlansky right
i think whoever said jordan who said
jordan in the chat brilliant
name this guy jordan i hope jordan's
watching you know sometimes jordan
watches these from his office
and i hope he's watching
[Music]
and not just any jordan it's gotta be
jordan schlansky
i hope all of you guys are actually
following jordan on on um
on all the platforms but uh instagram
yeah he's doing some great instagram
schlansky well jordan's a male age young
yeah he wishes uh let's go mature
class
uh
oh warrior's kind of good right
assassin
ah harold
harold we don't want to be a herald
thief
okay
uh
that's right
sorcerer and that's the robes are gonna
get caught on something well like this
guy's kind of brightly colored
pyromancer hair sort of jordan yeah
a cleric
i mean this guy looks jordan-esque oh i
mean
deprived
that is definitely jordan
level one oh my god wait this guy's all
tens
oh
whoa
wait a second
what
he's all tens
oh because he's got nothing else he
doesn't have any armor or anything
all right i guess let's just go uh
he's definitely a cleric knighter
warrior let's go wart ah let's go
knight let's go warrior all right
warrior seems kind of fun he's got a
cool helmet he's got great boots
where it is
burial gift
a life ring is that like a uh you know
purity ring or whatever a good
really includes item discovery what the
one use only
no no no let's just go life ring raises
xp all right face presets i don't care i
don't care it's fine finalize creation
boom done all right
there we go
that character though did he skip lunch
for the past two months never skipped
leg dre leg day live streaming games
never skip leg day
oh knight looks cooler than warrior all
right i chose i'm sorry that i chose
warrior but that's what did they say
oh god
went warrior sorry cha-cha charlie
oh here we go we're in it now we're in
it now dudes
[Music]
here we go
sombres i don't know the situation on
the tracer pose for overwatch so explain
it to me
what's up captain quasar i can see
oh here we are
this just looks lovely this time of year
i love it there it looks like we're in
prague maybe
eastern europe here we go is this us
so who knows what's the deal with dark
souls i don't really know a lot about it
we eat souls
or the bad guys eat souls and we're
stopping them we the lords of cinder
seem like bad guys
right
all right here we are
ooh cemetery of ash
what is our goal wait you mean like the
guy from pokemon yeah wait this is the
cemetery this is the pokemon graveyard
every time you die in pokemon you go
exactly oh i don't need to know this
okay close i don't i'm just learning i
don't need to read these messages okay i
i don't need to read these messages but
i will anyway
this guy's kind of slow i'm kind of
strong attack i'm kind of regretting the
choice of the warrior
who target lock
oh here we go let's
oh
this dude's wait what is that dude i
don't know i just killed him though was
i supposed to kill him do you kill guys
in this game i think back step is b
that's a roll okay we got a roll
situation
okay
okay
here we go got a little light thing here
i do eat souls in this game
the story is more of a thing on the side
it's more so about dying over and over
and over and over again since the gym
so it's like every other game i play is
there no running
kill everyone alright cool we'll do cool
thanks youtube chat once again you guys
are the best slash
the worst
so far game is not that hard
i've been pillaging some remains
like you do just enjoying the scenery oh
there's guard okay okay i got a uh i got
a shield oh i can hit with my shield
who rv behind the enemy critical hit got
it like this
okay got him really feel like i should
have chosen the knight
i'm regretting my decision guys
jesus
that's real dicks in this game all
right oh hey
who just shot that at me come here
my thing takes the wind up is crazy why
do we need to wind up you know he's like
uh did we get this game early is this
out yet
uh it comes out the 12th
that's right we got it before everyone
also they said uh they were like there's
a certain part i'm not supposed to show
in this game
and when we asked them because i was
like oh is it okay if we stream this
game like oh yeah and then they were
like oh it comes a couple hours in the
game and i was like
me getting a couple hours into this game
come on come on thank you for thinking
i'm not good but
i'm definitely not
although we're doing pretty well so far
lt is perry repel attack
what does that say repost what the hell
it's like a tumbler
replay yeah repost after okay so we can
rt
and then rb enemies should be nicer i
agree double stream on both websites
baby we're on twitch.tv and youtube.com
blade this is harder than bloodborne
jungle this is harder than bloodborne
impossible wait we were bad at
bloodborne we were terrible at
bloodborne i say we i mean i didn't
participate at all can i fall off the
edge of this thing you think oh it's
pretty should we test it or no let's
just no no
you know what i'm gonna fall off
eventually are these like droppings
on the cliff side wow this is really
pretty look at how beautiful this is
instead of fighting guys maybe we just
decide to like move here yeah is it like
can you like just take photos yeah can
we just like yeah can we take like a
selfie oh hey look
hey look we're coming out of this big
castle is that our house
jesus
wonder what the that's a pretty nice
airbnb i gotta say
rested bonfire all right
don't mind the fade way harder than
bloodborne yeah we'll see we'll see adam
dale if this is uh it's clemente says uh
hey look at look at us just chilling
okay we did it
we done rested all right let's go down
here
oh
well so far we are just cutting through
this like a knife through
soft
melted cheese you thought i was gonna
say butter didn't you
you know what i'm going to have to start
blocking
wow
i had my thing up though
oh i got him in the head you know what
no one survives a
axe today
like blood on
while dashing jump
i don't get it what do you mean about
that
dark soul 3 into farmington
no way to say yeah
i don't understand i had my shield up
there
boss coming up this will be funny says
steady chat we'll see this is the big
giant
yeah wait do we fight the end guy is
this the whole game
we might guys we might i think we got no
spoilers for dark shell three we might
have beaten the whole game yeah how do i
get over here there's a couple dudes
yeah all right
i do enjoy the fact that
what oh well
arrows aren't so
oh
wow man so far how many guys have i
killed like three hundred four hundred
this is e this game
oh this looks
totally the whole game
now
i'm no expert
but if you come upon a guy in a clearing
just kneeling down
i feel like that's a bad thing i feel
like he's good at his job yeah i feel
like this dude is good at yeah
and his job is killing me
now maybe we could just kind of sneak
along the side here and go around one
boss and done as the boss yeah maybe
this is the end of the game
you know what i will say this guy really
likes being surrounded by candles
because there are a lot of candles on
here and this looks like dry brush so
i'm not sure if i would leave this out
step one put out the candle yes well
yeah step one let's talk to this guy
about fire safety
and
well i think i just did something stupid
now see this game is forcing me to fight
i don't want to fight anybody oh dum dum
dum
this game is so epic says dory harden
that's right all right here we go
maybe we try talking to him first yeah
i'm trying to be diplomatic oh whoa wait
what happened to my weapons
oh got it back
all right sorry false alarm
uh
hey man
oh he's got something weird on his back
there beth
what is that
uh
some kind of growth
on his back
it's hair oh it's probably hair
oh let's remove the sword that's a great
idea
i don't i don't want to remove the sword
man
it's like a story all right let's do it
but a guy yeah it's like the sword and
the guy
whoa
well come back to life yeah see i knew
that was a dumb idea that was so stupid
why did we do that big stick this guy
looks gunder
jesus that's a
jesus christ that's a
whoa
can we just run away now nope
[ __ ]
oh god
oh boy that we're dead
look at how pretentious this guy he's
got great posture
luckily i'm a juke master oh you know
what we could do that we haven't done
here we go
we gotta yeah there we go we're
targeting on him it's just like rocket
league oh my god oh jesus
uh guys any tips in the chat
chat you want to help me out here dudes
that was
f prepare to die
fair to die is not a tip do some rolls i
think a dog got killed stick near his
feet and keep rolling run away simulator
oh we can't see the health bar someone's
saying
rolling block
there we go
chainmail armor why is it telling me
about chain now it's a history lesson
thanks
just like rocket league somebody said
it's basically rocket league
drop my shield said where's mikey
okay hey we start here that's kind of
cool is it too late for me to become a
knight
was it too late for me to not play this
game
nope
that's gonna that's
i gotta get some neosporin on that cut
it's gonna hurt
let's just
screw all these guys
oh dude
oh no come on hey oh hey look he fell
off
hi
hey what's down there
more bad guys
oh there's a soul down there is that
good should i go down there i'm gonna go
down here oh there's so many guys down
here oh this is dumb
oh i got killed
note to self don't jump down where guys
are
all right well that's two don't jump in
number two don't jump into two juked
drop your shield perfect
bee's music yeah what's our uh what's
our kill count
got wrecked
pro tip don't die thanks theo jolif
oh man hit them off hit them off down
there is death i should have been the
knight i think this is can i switch guys
can i change dudes somehow whoops wait
what did i just do whoops oh no what am
i doing
uh can i change guys
can i change guys though
can i change guys
look at that idiot it does kind of help
when i die that it's jordan no offense
jordan
you know what i'm gonna go this way
let's dodge this dude oh man this guy
how's that feel
just two
yeah just two okay i'm not that bad
jesus one more question mark
oh right in the kidney oh yeah
take it
we're just joking these guys whoo
over here yup missed me okay
note to self oh wait what's this thing
hey
hey cool i got some souls oh you know
what that must be where i died last time
wait why is there why is there a big
waterfall now
um
traversal
you can't just walk
oh now it's this guy again
can i just hit this dude in the butt
what about if i hit him in the butt
oh
oh
he's got a big old sword you know this
isn't very
fair
you have health food
oh god damn it stay close and roll to
dodge
yeah thanks i'm trying
that's a typical level hello
oh he's got oh my god what's this oh
jesus christ this is on why is he got a
big lizard head oh
no
no
no
no
not fair
not fair he's turning into a half lizard
man
bro
you gotta get that seen by a doctor
i'm unhappy with this situation
oh this is not this is incredibly hard
don't oh come on man
almost
he's definitely not like all lizard
jesus i can't even see how
this is not
okay killed him nice
yeah what's up now half lizard man
hey got a cold sword that's cool
i got a hot flash am i going through
menopause yep you're aging perfect
we need a kill count or are we good no
we didn't die we didn't oh nice kill
count two
you could make it a little smaller in
the corner jesus that's kind of passive
aggressive yeah what a d jason o'malley
dick
legless lizard that was yeah that was
not cool zasty fun reel we did it yo
uh all right get the sword oh let's
light that bonfire though
bam light it up load it up load it up
yeah that's right dude that was uh we
didn't take a load off that was a lot
rename it death counts all right
oh yeah it's death count you're right
it's death count uh okay we did it sat
down for a minute
i noticed i'm starting to have some
weird fire issues
is that
you know what's up with that
why am i all like burnt up
oh wait maybe i can change to my sword
now
equipment let's change to us oh we don't
have the
wait
i i thought there was a
isn't there a thing did i not
but what the
the thing though
it's your inner embers wait we can i
thought i had a sword or something no
didn't the mofo drop a sword
he had a big he had a big old sword i
don't get that sword i probably can't
hold it it's probably bigger than you oh
man what a bummer
fine ugh let down it's like when i was a
kid i thought i was gonna get battle
damage skeletor for christmas i didn't
get jack [ __ ] i was [ __ ] really upset
it always happened always happens
[Music]
they need to oil these hinges this is
not
good
oh it dissolved while i pulled it out of
the guy says vex venati thank you vex
all right here we go
well
i think we just beat the game right that
was easy yeah that's it
so far first guy
thought we were gonna you know we should
have known when there was that weird
stuff on his neck that he was gonna turn
into a giant half lizard salamander man
yeah i hate salamanders frankly there's
colleen little like
snakes with feet
wet snakes with feet if it's not there
you didn't get it
i don't know what that means all right
here we go
oh man ah this doesn't look good come on
a throne room
and what is every you know
if i'm gonna move to the dead souls
universe i'm definitely
definitely opening a candle business
yeah i would make so much money there
are so many candles in this game look at
this we should have a candle count i
don't even know if numbers go that high
i'm going to be honest with you guys
should we just jump down here
oh
man i gotta go near this big throne ugh
this is gonna go really bad
hey what's back here what does it say
let's read engraving holy king lothric
last hope of his line
that's like me that's a lot of pressure
yep probably you know the last king
probably had problems dating yeah yeah
definitely yeah there's no queen he was
on tinder
tinder has a whole nother meeting when
you're a lord of cinder
this is not a very
they need to
you need to get some like clorox wipes
or something on that thing that's
there's a growth
look at all these freaking candles man
who's so who's lighting the candles hey
who's lighting the candles b
you can't tell me that there's no
breeze in here
yeah all the candles are going to stay
lit i've tried to light a candle all
right looks pretty drafty
yorm the giant of the profaned capital
everyone has these
really epic names
it should be a zero count of kills
because the boss was the tutorial
and it doesn't count
but that was a tutorial
i'm just gonna not talk to this lady
because i know she's gonna ask me to go
on some quest
oh the
king
needs his special touchstone back
from the profane
artist of the t oh ludliff the exiled
does no one have a name just like gary
nope
gary the disappointing
[Laughter]
you know what i'm saying what about
craig the unfortunate of the sadness
realm like there's nobody just nobody
has a normal name in these games all
candles and a lot of consonants where
they shouldn't be in names all right
let's talk to her she's going to make us
do something
just my name's jordan schlansky thank
you
she looks like a girl from eyes wide
shut the mask
what do you mean by tend to me
delivered with an apostrophe that's
pretty pretentious delivery delivered
today
oh let's level up dude
no chat
oh well well but i shouldn't i take you
to dinner
first but i barely know you oh my god
there is so much writing on the screen
right now
holy [ __ ] all right
let's try to make some sense of this
[Music]
what am i supposed to do here
this is like baseball maybe you choose
one choose attribute to level up okay
okay what do we want to level up i
always think health is good right guys
what should i what should i level up
yeah standing jams makes a good point
delivered with an apostrophe doesn't
shorten the word no it's equal length
jordan the passive
so many numbers uh all right what guys
what do you think here
be wise in your choice as a zera eh
reading brain hurts luck strength
level nothing but luck the whole game
okay
health and stamina that strength i think
tanker knows what's up
endurance strength vitality
luck
strength and i've seen a lot of
endurance and strength
level up your mom thanks real city once
again youtube chat represent level up i
can't believe that got through all the
isis comments all right
oh japanese makes a good point it's
jordan he would level up intelligence
that's true strength
strength
uh shady says endurance strength
i guess endurance
strength for warrior all right you know
a lot of people are saying strength
oh we can do a couple things here
oh okay
we can do two
we'll do strength and endurance
let's do it all right we're doing it
level up your social skills well good
well played
jokes
that's right
thank you uh adirus yendin in the
youtube chat says you love you thank you
i appreciate that you're representing uh
the youtube chat well
uh vigor for health luck vigor
everyone's saying who's played this game
why am i listening to people
no all right good if i'm new to the jar
all right this is what we're doing yes
we're leveling up let's do it
we did it everybody
oh wait select another we already did
that though
we selected an attribute everyone we did
it
i i did that already though
i did i did do that
i didn't i select the tribute we all saw
me select the attribute
and i did it
okay good
should we talk some more just leave it's
time to go all right
yeah later thanks for letting me touch
your darkness
anytime i'll i'll call you okay don't
worry i'll i'll tell i'll text you we
don't
i'll text you don't worry about it
oh
i was going to ask if this guy's a good
guy or a bad guy but he hasn't attacked
me yet so it's probably good
and also look dude you're going to want
to put a hair net over that you don't
want your newcomer
he's like
with an overly large beard and white
hair
yeah of course dude why else would i be
here bro
oh yeah
i've never had anyone smitten some
weapons
all right reinforce repair
let's do it reinforce the asterisk what
do you want to do a lot i don't know
what to do
let's infuse let's repair equipment
what do i do here anybody
this is my safe zone says tanker thank
you
reinforce weapon let's reinforce all
these people are your people they're my
peeps
i don't have that let's reinforce the
old battle axe
okay can't do it perfect
uh
infused weapon
did you infuse it don't know
can't do it
okay great repair equipment
can't do it perfect this is really going
well so far
a lot estes
i don't know what these are doing
uh i haven't tried me meet emoji yet uh
oh collect tight knight and come back to
him later okay done canceling allotment
fine
be careful
prithee
you know
that laugh makes me think you
are a dick all right here we go
all right let's get out of here
we're trailing sparks let's go
a lot of candles a lot of candles so
many candles you know where it's a great
place to not put candles on the stairs
you know it's really knocked over
how do we get out of here
[Music]
you know what this needs is a sprint
function
okay can't go this way
geez oh pete's i guess we just come out
of here the same way we got in
all right
somebody literally said i could easily
train conan for the next 1 million
uh major if he wants
some pocket money
conan is plenty of pocket money trust me
hey who's this guy hey there pal
another one
why so glum
you know what dude get your negative
vibes away from me man i don't need any
of that yeah go go go be sad and listen
to radiohead on your own time i got
lords of cinder to kill you see me with
that salamander guy i was like bladder
how do i get out of here please someone
hold b to sprint hold b to sprint
oh yes
oh yes whoever said that thank you
can this lady
now i've touched your darkness it's like
awkward between us
you know every when i after i touch a
girl's darkness it's the things it
changes the whole thing i can't get out
of the room it changes yeah change i'm
all flustered it changes our whole
relationship
she's moving too fast i'm sorry
all right here we go
man they gotta they gotta do something
about these candles they get this is so
many candles
dude how do we oh man this is
isn't it funny that
that
uh namco thought i would actually get to
a point where i might show some spoilers
this is the worst there's any kind of
map function on here oh man
okay let's retrace our steps i remember
there were stairs and candles
[Laughter]
i'm sorry
uh okay we came in this way i think up
here right
okay here we go outside thank god jesus
you know you could put a fire exit sign
in there you got so many candles how
about putting a fire exit sign
okay
okay okay here we go
all right now where to go where to go
that's a
really nice castle okay down here i
guess
oh here's a soul
slurp this right up
okay slurp slurp slurp
uh
cool
oh wait i see some bad guys
time to do some killing
yeah nice shield this didn't really help
you
just slurping up souls slurp slurp a
homeward bone
and i touched girls darkness already i
got a homeward bone this game is pretty
sexual
you know that's probably why it's like a
mature title yeah probably innuendo yeah
a lot of sex talk
okay read message
open menu
great all right cool well this is going
very well i think
if i just go back the way i came or
i mean we were going up here
i don't want to go back into this whole
thing though
big gulp
yeah dude i agree it's a boring game to
watch you're not fighting a boss i
completely agree maybe we go around the
castle
thoughts
ah jesus christ
holy crap scared the [ __ ] out of me what
even is that oh my god
oh jesus
wow that was freaky that scared the crap
out of me
oh my god
take back what i said about this game
being boring
that was horrifying
oh i can't scare people like that
skeleton dog
ah
this game is pretty though
i guess i gotta go back in here
oh man come on
better color palette
uh
i'm starting to think the flames is
really bad uh oh by the way oh somebody
said go back and embed the sword in
front of the woman got it got it okay i
gotta take the broken sword
and give it to the lady
ah here we go embed the coiled sword
here we go thank you youtube chat
killing it right now love it
[Music]
was that death count
we haven't died yet all right o'malley
we've only died twice god i just want to
keep it up i did update the kill count
though that's good okay here we go
i enjoy any game that one of the menu
options is burn undead bone shard all
right travel let's travel
no don't i'm here no please no
i wanted to go to the high wall i didn't
want to go back to where i just was ugh
i'm not doing it on purpose i swear
franken
i'm not ignoring you guys
you guys don't need to put your minds
together i'm watching
damn daniel
all right we're back at the shrine where
we just were all right here we go we're
going to travel
everyone is so upset at me
here we go we're going to travel the
high wall of lothic
otherwise known as
ypsilanti michigan
multicast
that's right
someone pull up on the tutorial so the
love is against this jeez
i don't hate you guys you know who hates
me
dark souls 3 hates me guys you're just
joining us we're playing dark souls 3 on
the old xbox one
uh or xbox uh ani which is what i call
it that's actually the real name it's
actually not xbox everyone says it wrong
everyone says it wrong it's xbox ani uh
traitor says jace
a thrusting sword
that's something
all right so far we got touching we've
touched a girl's darkness we've got a
homeward bone and now we're going to get
a thrusting sword this game is all this
game is extremely
sexually frustrating oh look at this is
that some soup is this something yeah
there's some soup over here
this looks like the scene of a party
like 400 years ago and that's the punch
all right here we go let's get out let's
get out in the world and kill some stuff
still think we should have chosen
tonight
this is a game you drink to yeah it's x
bone oh fair enough
whoa
high wall of lothric
look at this i hope there are high guard
railings on those uh
those bridges because that's pretty
unsafe
why did i drink that that was really
stupid
we showed them
we got those boxes that'll teach those
boxes to talk back to us
right
how guys boxes do we kill
for oh
this isn't that's not a good sign when
you see a bunch of
people tree people
yikes
you see how i did that i was just like
boom imagine if i could do that like
when a girl smokes just like like flame
her up
all right
spraying a bunch of chairs that are uh
i guess those are
don't know i hate rocking chairs so this
so far is the best part of the game for
me
just be a chair you know
i don't trust rocking chairs you never
know where you s you stand with them or
where you're sitting i guess
all right here we go
well
i will say there are less candles down
here so that's an improvement
oh this is
this is not gonna go well i don't like
them this is not gonna go well maybe we
could just kind of walk around walk past
these people
yep
no that was gonna happen
knew that was gonna happen
[Music]
oh there are candles over here damn it
knew there were going to be candles
should i just be killing all these
people i should definitely be killing
this guy
oh it takes a couple hits
i feel like the guys
oh jesus
gotta be on the lookout here i got a
firebomb
anybody else
i feel like this guy i should murder
right because this guy's gonna try to
come at me i think
all right got him
oh man look hey they're praying to a big
uh big dragon thing big dead dragon i
wonder if that'll come alive yeah
probably
knowing my luck in this game
you know the people yeah the tree people
are kind of that's that's that's real
creepy that's not a good look
uh
man oh man
i'm getting slightly gooders at somebody
slightly
where's my oh yeah come on
they're mad you wrecked their furniture
oh jeez yeah i know they're so pissed i
destroyed their ikea furniture
binoculars come on bro
nothing to the barrel
well
when i crawl up this or something can i
crawl up something nope
it is really windy up here
boxes take that you know what i'm great
at killing boxes
uh something tells me we've got to go
back down the world hey oh hey there's a
guy
i just like fell down on that guy whoops
all right
i hear like growling somewhere
oh man look there's like people around
the dragon thing oh man that thing is
totally gonna come to life and
kill me
okay
that thing is totally gonna come to life
gold pine resin good that'll be good for
my bow oh this is
bad
there's a lot of stuff to kill in here
though destroy
can i like creep around somehow probably
not
yeah i see you over there in the boxes
i think you're so smart i'm
i'm behind those boxes
jesus
oh
i'm gonna drink some of my potion
get me back up there nice little stout
ale bringing me back to life
i just assumed this guy would be drunk
all the time because he uh
has to fight terrible demons
oh man destroying furniture ah it's just
so stressful
finding demons and it's just so nice
we want to jump down in there slap the
dragon
do i want to jump down in here
i mean i guess i have to right oh god
the worst all right let's go
uh oh you know what we could actually
wait we came in through where
couldn't we go up here
oh this is that place that we don't
oh my god we just fought all those guys
we didn't have to do that we could have
just come down in here i'm so stupid all
right
well after we die we could come back
that'll be a nice place to
perfect
dark souls 3 ridding the world of
barrels and furniture
you should get more life for killing
furniture i'm saying i'm just saying
that that should be a thing
i'm giving you lots of credit
oh boy here we go here we go nope nope
dodging them all dodging them all f you
oh jesus christ ah
yeah
i knew that dragon was oh jesus oh now
i'm on fire i'm on fire
i'm definitely on fire oh boy oh god i'm
on fire now i'm dead i'm dead i knew
that dragon was gonna come back to life
i knew it
damn it
this was stupid
man
oh
it's so scary this game is scary man
it's freaking me out
ah where do i even go now i don't
remember
oh that's right down the stairs all
right we're going to just run through
all this [ __ ]
running through running through sorry i
guess i should kill this dude
ah hey
i do like it when i just
i just wave my axe in the air 50 times
idiot
i'm gonna start using the targeting
function more i think that's what's been
hurting me
oh
oh the head crusher
that's a nice move
if i do say so myself and since everyone
else is dead because i kill them i think
i'll have to
i see you over there chopper
yeah what now
try to hide behind some boxes
oh jesus all right so why did some
ketchup come out of me i think that was
bad did you see o'malley's furniture
kill thing
no how much brilliant you got furniture
killed oh dude
yeah keep up on that furniture
oh man you know what i'm gonna get some
extra furniture count going over here
let's hear three more that's that's a
four or five
that's six more at least i'll be good at
one thing in this game
killing furniture here we go here we go
all right
all right i'm gonna drink some potion
because we know that this mofo is coming
back
yup
what's up now do a little dance i'm
going to
where am i going where am i going i'm
coming in nope i'm going away i'm coming
in
nope oh
yeah that definitely sounds like a
dragon
oh
jesus christ christ
you know what forget this guy no screw
you
i'm out of here
what is happening
oh jesus god oh my god
how are you supposed to kill that oh my
god what
what oh
boy
what
is going on okay you know what wait
maybe we could use the fire to kill
these other dudes
all right what oh my god all right what
are we doing here what are we doing we
can't fight this thing right
go kill the dragon drops good loot what
how
okay here we go we're just going for it
let's go let's go
oh that killed me
oh how would a letdown
super dead damn it use the shield
i have no blood
the fire heals me yeah right whatever
goklitz
it's a tarp
hit the dragon in the balls i'm not sure
that's the thing all right here we go
hope these people know they have a big
dragon problem on their hands i will say
i do like the fact that um
i do like the fact that uh you start off
oh sorry
whoops well i can pillage this corpse
i'm not just gonna leave a pair of
deserted trousers there
it
this guy's just swiping left and right
ow
all right
i keep thinking b is the attack button
and so i'm just like jumping around like
a madman
all right here we go
b is the sprint button you know what
screw this guy i'm done with this room
we're just leaving it let's go we don't
care about that room let's go
we don't care about that room
all right now we got a dragon situation
ouch
no oh god jesus god
i didn't think the fire would come down
this way
can i get past it though
oh look at me just juke all these guys
whoa let's go yeah oh my god
oh but then
got the knife got me
oh that was great all right new plan
we're just running past all those guys i
don't need to fight all those guys
why would i that's ridiculous
one day that ladder will be used and the
fall damage will be avoided today is not
that day all right you know what just
for you person who said that in the chat
i'm gonna use the latter
for you i didn't realize it was fall
damage
all right
let's go we're going to kill this dude
quick
oh man god i keep thinking that one
button is attack and it's not
idiot where's the other guy up here who
tries to hit me where is he where is he
really you don't help in this game if i
had a gun
oh perfect that dude's over here
target lock is your friend i'm trying to
target lock him but
it's not helping when i think the jump
or the dodge button is the freaking
sponsored by nike yeah exactly all right
we're using this ladder descent
yeah let's just do it as slow as
possible don't worry about it like 50
dudes chase oh great
this you know whoever said use the
ladder that's awesome this is ridiculous
did i just
can i punch downwards perhaps
pithy
you know
all right whoever in the chat said use
the ladder
wrong i would rather take fall damage
than what happened i hope you're happy
right in the butt right straight up in
the pooper
oh there's no death like at pooper death
uh all i want to do is get past the
dragon i think we can do it
straight up the butt
ugh what's our furniture count death at
422.
we gotta get that higher we got to get
over 500.
here we go
all right kill this dude quick
do a juke
hit him with the chopper and chop a chew
a chip of chop
number two should i just murder all
these people i mean they all suck right
this guy this
yep yep oh yeah
why don't you fling your knife a little
bit more yeah oh yeah
look at that perfect no damage here we
go
bring it
i got i got the lock on you baby
nice
master lock situation all right not
using the ladder so don't even worry
about it oh recover oh no i want to
recover those souls though no no
oh geez
that's a good camera angle for fighting
someone
all right i gotta recover those souls
that's gotta happen
look at my butt
you know for someone who fights a lot my
butt is not that toned
and you want i
upon further inspection
really the warriors boots do not look
that cool yeah you know i thought they
kind of look cool but they don't
all right boom
okay here we go
all right
are we ready are we ready
let's go jukum
jukem
count jukes a lot ouch
now i'm on fire
now i'm on fire now i'm on fire nope
juked them
get through get through go go go go go
juked them
let's go
there's a knight over here so i'm just
going to take a quick breather to get
the soul of a duster kidding corpse here
comes somebody after me
juked him
died i didn't die get up
juked him
let's go let's go let's go let's go
all right let's run through this thing
no problem let's just run up this way oh
man this game is so easy
hey i'd like to light this bonfire
please
hello
oh wow they really oh he's coming they
really chased after you in this game oh
no i thought that was the attack button
damn it
you know what i gotta say running by
everybody really does work in this game
uh how do we oh look at this and i let
the bonfire boom
guys that's how it's done friends ah now
we're just taking a rest
we must have juked 50 dudes
just juked right past him
that's right so perfect
yeah no i'm not killing the dragon so
don't worry about it
oh my god that was easy oh you know what
it's three o'clock is it it's three
o'clock guys i think that's going to do
it for today
dark souls 3. you know what i think
we're going to play some more in this
game it's fun on monday we had a good
time i like this right what do you guys
think more dark souls 3 on monday
that could be fun like yeah running
souls exactly
uh exactly um but this is awesome guys
thank you for joining us once again game
was dark souls 3.
it was great happy tuesday wait final
furniture
final furniture count and by the way
we're going to keep this furniture count
for monday
it's at 4 33
the kill counts 25 the death count is at
seven so this is a pretty good number
that's a pretty good ratio guys i'm
pretty proud of myself
maximum zebra are you kidding me this is
the worst stream correct this is the
absolute worst stream you're right uh
we'll see you guys on monday we'll play
a little bit longer on monday i'm sorry
we got a show to do today
that's good love you guys go clicks jace
soccer man uh kids arutha raven gigi for
reza
uh serpent serpico mitch b
mitch b i noticed you alright see you
guys later see you monday bye
you